ahora la tierra empezaba a ser adecuada
para los animales y otros seres como
nosotros anteriormente vimos que durante
el león proterozoica el oxígeno empezó a
acumularse en la atmósfera provocando la
primera glaciación y la extinción masiva
de las especies anaerobias pero eso a su
vez hizo que las condiciones fueran
aptas para las células eucariotas y aún
más importante las células eucariotas
fueron capaces de formar organismos
multicelulares eso es lo que veremos
ahora la vida multicelular empieza aquí
pero recuerden que todo esto se mueve
constantemente conforme se descubren
nuevas cosas en los registros geológicos
y además cada vez tenemos más
herramientas a nuestra disposición así
que estos números se van ajustando pero
bueno esto nos da una buena idea de
acuerdo a lo que conocemos hasta ahora
así podemos saber en dónde empezaron a
aparecer o surgir las cosas y
coincidiendo con la vida multicelular
es muy interesante porque tiene un gran
efecto en la evolución también comienza
la reproducción sexual inicia la
reproducción sexual esto tuvo un gran
impacto en la evolución porque antes las
variaciones en el adn dependían
completamente de las mutaciones
movimientos aleatorios del adn o incluso
de algunos virus pero ahora con la
reproducción sexual empieza a existir
una mezcla sistemática de adn con lo que
hay más variación en los genes
permitiendo que haya más selección
porque hay más variedad para seleccionar
y así ocurre una aceleración en el ritmo
de la evolución y bueno investigue en
muchas fuentes y dicen que esto ocurrió
hace aproximadamente 1.2 o 1.5 mil
millones de años hace un poco más de mil
millones de años fue que empezaron las
formas de vida multicelular y la
reproducción sexual y otra cosa de la
que hablamos en el brote
y fue que la acumulación de oxígeno
permitió que se formara la capa de ozono
el ozono consiste en tres átomos de
oxígeno por eso es o tres y al final de
león' proterozoica es decir hace
aproximadamente 550 millones de años
digo aproximadamente porque pudo haber
sido 100 millones de años antes o
después recuerden que esto se mueve
constantemente pero bueno
aproximadamente en ese tiempo la capa de
ozono empezó a ser lo suficientemente
densa para proteger la tierra de los
rayos uvb como vimos en el vídeo
anterior hablamos de que la tierra es
bombardeada con rayos uvb y la capa de
ozono es lo único que nos protege de esa
radiación solar lo que permite que los
animales terrestres podamos vivir
entonces coincidiendo en ese periodo
hace aproximadamente 550 millones de
años la vida empezó a colonizar la
tierra entonces
colonizar la tierra y esto fue muy
interesante para mí cuando lo aprendí
por primera vez porque siempre supuse
que los árboles y el pasto siempre
fueron parte de la tierra pero resulta
que los animales colonizaron la tierra
antes que las plantas las plantas no
colonizaron la tierra sino hasta hace
450 millones de años aproximadamente en
otro vídeo les aclaro bien a qué me
refiero con esto y bueno ahora nos
encontramos al final de león'
proterozoica la vida empieza a colonizar
la tierra y ya existe la capa de ozono
pero después ocurre otra glaciación
cerca del final de león' proterozoica
ocurre la segunda glaciación y existen
muchas teorías sobre por qué ocurrió y
por qué desapareció tal vez por los
volcanes o por los gases de efecto
invernadero quién sabe pero conforme
entramos al final de esta glaciación
podemos ver que la vida empezaba a
florecer y empieza a florecer
conforme entramos al león faner o soy co
no está marcado pero corresponde a esta
parte lo escribiré todo esto corresponde
a león fan ero soy co y se divide en
todas estas eras antes teníamos leones y
aquí son eras los leones se dividen en
eras y cada era es de cientos de
millones de años aquí tenemos la era
paleozoica la era mesozoica y la era
cenozoica que es la era en la que nos
encontramos actualmente pero tal vez lo
más interesante bueno no quiero tener
favoritos pero una de las heras más
interesantes es la primera la era
paleozoica en esta era
tenemos el período cámbrico tal vez ya
lo hayan escuchado este es el período
cámbrico ok y durante este periodo la
tierra experimentó la llamada explosión
cámbrica que fue una explosión en el
número y tipo de especies y géneros que
existían la biodiversidad
planeta porque recuerden que ya existía
la capa de ozono como protección y la
tierra ya empezaba a ser colonizada
además de que ya había un ambiente rico
en oxígeno y así empezaron a surgir
organismos multicelulares cada vez más
complejos y si nos adelantamos algunos
millones de años aparece el primer pez y
también empezamos a ver los primeros
tipos de organismos proto anfibios y si
nos adelantamos más conforme salimos del
período cámbrico empezamos a ver la
existencia de plantas entonces aquí ya
teníamos a las plantas terrestres pero
recuerden que nada de esto es exacto
porque se va moviendo conforme
descubrimos nuevas cosas y me sorprende
que muchas de las cosas que consideramos
fundamentales para la tierra en realidad
son fenómenos muy recientes a mí me
sorprendió mucho saber que las plantas
aparecieron en la tierra hace
aproximadamente 450 millones de años y
que los insectos no
existían sino hasta hace 400 millones de
años los reptiles aparecieron hace 300
millones de años más o menos por aquí
los mamíferos aparecieron hace 200
millones de años y los pájaros
aparecieron hace 150 millones de años y
toda la era de los dinosaurios que de
por sí la consideramos muy lejana a
nosotros prácticamente ocurrió en la era
mesozoica esta es la era de los
dinosaurios pero cuando analizamos el
reloj geológico podemos ver que fue
relativamente reciente y que termina con
bueno al menos lo que se cree hasta
ahora que termina con el impacto de un
enorme meteorito de 10 kilómetros de
diámetro contra la tierra
específicamente en donde ahora es la
península de yucatán en méxico
justo a un lado de la península de
yucatán y destruyó todas las formas de
vida grandes que existían en la tierra
especialmente los dinosaurios
y bueno lo que les decía es que me
sorprendió mucho que las plantas
aparecieron hace 450 millones de años
pero el pasto que yo lo veo como algo
muy importante en la naturaleza el pasto
apareció hace 40 a 70 millones de años
el pasto es relativamente nuevo en el
planeta y las flores aparecieron hace
aproximadamente 130 millones de años así
que existió una época en la que había
dinosaurios pero no había flores ni
pasto y si nos adelantamos más al
analizar esta escala es un poco chistoso
porque miren este es el período en el
que existieron los dinosaurios y esta
línea café indica la aparición de los
mamíferos
entonces los dinosaurios aparecieron
junto con los mamíferos y después los
dinosaurios murieron pero cuando el
asteroide impactó en la tierra tal vez
nuestros ancestros estaban ocultos en
escondites o algo por el estilo pero de
lo que sí estoy
segura es de que la mayoría de los
mamíferos grandes desaparecieron y bueno
cuando analizamos este periodo
aquí nos pusieron un punto muy pequeño
no se alcanza a ver pero dice que hace
dos millones de años aparecieron los
primeros humanos vaya esto es muy
considerado al decir primeros humanos
porque en realidad fueron los primeros
proto manos porque los primeros humanos
que ya eran como nosotros no existieron
sino hasta hace aproximadamente 200 a
400 mil años más o menos así que este es
un periodo en el que si bien aparecieron
los primeros protón humanos los humanos
como nosotros aparecieron hace 200 mil
años y sólo para darles una idea de qué
tan nuevo somos y de qué tan nueva es
nuestra evolución miren es de sólo 5
millones de años aquí son 0 años y el
homo sapiens aparicio hace
aproximadamente 200 mil años y los
neandertales
fueron como sus primos porque no fueron
nuestros ancestros muchas personas
piensan que sí pero más bien eran una
especie muy similar provenían de la
misma raíz bueno aunque ahora hay
teorías de que tal vez se hayan mezclado
con los homo sapiens así que algunos de
nosotros podríamos tener algo de adn
neandertal y eso no debe verse como un
insulto porque ellos tenían grandes
cerebros bueno no necesariamente el
cerebro pero si la cabeza y al parecer
eso implica un cerebro grande bueno en
realidad no lo sabemos y generalmente
tendemos a hacerlos menos pero yo no
creo que tengamos que clasificarlos
simplemente quiero decirles que esto
ocurrió apenas hace 200.000 años y hace
dos millones de años apenas surgieron
los primeros proto humanos y bueno
nuestro árbol genealógico diverge de los
chimpancés hace cinco millones de años
que si lo dibujamos en este reloj
geológico serían dos píxeles porque no
se alcanza
pero aquí es en donde los ancestros de
los humanos empezaron a divergir de los
chimpancés espero que esto les ayude a
entender mejor todo esto por lo menos a
mí me dio una mejor idea de cómo
sucedieron las cosas